[Music]
i wonder if my mom is still fat
anyway
where is cody i swear he's always late
or am i
what are you doing
i'm not late i'm actually early for next
week's podcast
what is this this whole demeanor you
have right now
oh well i decided you know after i
didn't get the prime time uh multicam
sitcom i thought maybe we'd incorporate
some elements from that into this show
so i could really show my stuff show
what i got you know
so
booga
well you aren't showing much
um
yes i am
[Applause]
man i really wish i could beam up
that suit
who said no to me who rejected me so i
could show them what i got
especially now with this live studio
audience maybe i could really show them
you know
show them more than just a
wee little podcaster
i think that's doable candice can we get
the suit that rejected cody wait you're
you can
yeah
oh
no
yeah
[Applause]
ugh
you again
oh i i
i'm sorry i didn't i wasn't prepped for
this i didn't i didn't think you were
actually gonna
beam this guy up so i don't really have
any like jokes or anything
well i don't know what to say you said
you wanted to show your stuff
why don't you
i don't know
show them what you got yeah okay yeah
yeah okay give me something and i'll
show you i can improv
a funny scene
give me something hmm
well you weren't funny the last time so
how about
wonkavision
yeah
okay you're home
you just watched willy wonka
you hit the old piece pipe
and now you're getting blasted to a
a gay cowboy bar in alabama
that's pretty good was it not i mean i
i tried to incorporate all the elements
and i don't i'm nervous man
can you give me something give me
something
uh okay
you're the rope that killed epstein
that's good
it's not good that's really good it's
massively inappropriate i would never be
on a prime time sitcom or would it not
stop laughing it's not that's not good
that's definitely good that's not good
that's not a good one okay let me try
though
i i don't know i'm trying i don't know
what stop these aren't even real give me
give me one more
okay
you're the jailer that found epstein no
i know
and you're pissed because you would just
order dinner and now he's dead in his
cell
go
maybe you should walk into it okay walk
into it good idea yep okay
oh what the [ __ ] is this
you forgot you still have dinner waiting
my lean cuisine's gonna get cold
thank you
[Applause]
so did i get it
did you reconsider
i think i did pretty good
well
it was
a little bit better than the audition
you did i gotta give you that but just
not enough for me to convince the rest
of the suits that you're the one
what's funny don't laugh at that well
that's funny
that's not funny that's hilarious
nothing about this is funny this hasn't
been funny the whole time oh it's been
hysterical it's not it's stopped stop
laughing like that what's going on
oh man now that's cringe
why is this happening
now that is
you